salut aujourd'hui on va avoir dix idées
reçues trop répandue sur le cerveau de
la plus répandue à la moins répandue et
vous allez voir que plus on avance plus
ça peut énerver un peu je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard cette vidéo
n'est pas un affront à mon existe depuis
toujours max bird que nous tape au ton
gentiment sur le bec
mais reprenons depuis les plus grosse
bêtise qui circule sur le cerveau loïc
c'est le générique
oui oui c'est logique et on commence par
la fin de facto numéro 08 et un rajout
d'où cette coupe de confinement le
cerveau a besoin de jouer pour apprendre
pour éprouver du plaisir et de la
motivation bien la dopamine et ça tombe
bien car pour ça cette vidéo et en
partenariat avec crucell castel un jour
vous allez regarder le seigneur d'un
château médiéval les amis la dopamine de
la réussite va couler dans vos neurones
comme vous avez déjà pu le voir sur ma
chaîne youtube sur un grand fan de jeux
de rôle et là j'ai clairement
l'impression de faire un truc un peu
ambiance donjons et dragons mais moderne
avec des personnages un peu cartoon et
le jeu est plutôt drôle aussi en tout
cas plus que loïc moi je suis pas le
rôle tu veux me le payer fabien l'écart
qu'est ce qu'il y aille a embrouillé
battue c'est quoi tu t'inscris
gratuitement tu cherches mon clan et
soit tu rejoins mon clan soit tu peux
attaquer ma forteresse et dans
l'hypothèse improbable que tu réussisses
à gagner tu pour appliquer mes
ressources pour améliorer ton château
vous pourrez aussi vous battre contre
des hordes des squelettes des géants des
dragons pour essayer de vaincre le
terrible seigneur abyssal dévolu à coup
dans le coude dans le coude
les combats sont vraiment fun l'on prend
plaisir à terrasser les autres mais moi
ce que je préfère c'est la gestion du
château on peut construire de nouveaux
locaux et développer de nouveaux
personnages allant de du cuisinier
jusqu'au tanks et les améliorer ta van
wyk télécharge et installe custom via
mon lien ci-dessous entrez votre surnom
et obtenez un bonus spécial pour les
nouveaux joueurs de 250 diamant et 3500
qui est art et vous avez que quand vous
passez par là méliand vous soutenez la
chaîne et vous découvrez un jeu coup
en dixième position il y a la fabuleuse
légende que les marques que connaîtrait
les secrets pour manipuler de cerveau
nous faire acheter ce qu'ils veulent
mais non toi t'as pas du tout du second
tour n'est aujourd'hui
ben alors les marques travaille depuis
très longtemps l'aspect émotionnel de
leurs campagnes marketing
on est bien d'accord le but du jeu quand
tu crées un bon produit ou encore
services
c'est quand même que les gens s'y
intéressent il travaille donc sur des
pistes d influence de déclencheur
cognitif ou émotionnelle l'idée étant de
faire basculer le client potentiel vers
1h à 6,2 base il est déjà intéressée
vers 7h à la potentielle mans ok loi
parce que moi par exemple si je n'ai pas
le permis
binger pas tant envie de l'acheter une
voiture ouais mais ça marche pas tu es
tu là mon père me loïc ouais mais là
c'est pas la question n'est pas faux ces
recherches ont commencé depuis ben
depuis toujours en fait bien avant
l'apparition des neurosciences et malgré
tout le tous leurs efforts et toutes les
études lancées sur le sujet n'y a pas de
technique vraiment de manipulation qui
permettrait de déclencher un achat
automatique chez quelqu'un dont il
optimise plus ou moins finement mais on
est très loin du fantasme de la
manipulation de cerveau pour faire
acheter des trucs en neuvième position
les gauchers utiliserait plus leur
cerveau droit que leur cerveau gauche et
tu as raison
loïc génériques si le ciel est dégagé on
peut voir le soleil
par contre n'est pas obligé de faire un
ag as.g machin dès que je prononce le
mot donc le truc des cerveaux droit et
gauche c'est au mieux une image au pire
une métaphore on a quand même deux
émissaires distincts le médecin paul
broca qui donnera son nom plus tard aux
airs de broca dans le cerveau à les voir
en 1861 que l'hémisphère gauche
contenait la zone de la parole et il en
a déduit après que ça continue aussi les
zones de langage et les zones de logique
non pas aux docks si loïc il a ensuite
déduit que le côté droit gérer
l'imaginaire et la créativité et c'est
ainsi qu'est née l'image du cerveau
gauche du cerveau droit alors qu'en
réalité il ya les mêmes réunions de
chaque côté du cerveau mais en temps
normal c'est l'ère du mouvement de
l'hémisphère gauche
il gère l'écriture donc on écrit de la
main droite parce que c'est croiser tout
ça mais certaines personnes ont cette
même zone plus développé dans leur
hémisphère droit et écrivent donc ont
croisé de la main gauche
aucun rapport avec le truc de cerveau
droit et du cerveau gauche qui serait
plus utilisés souvent qu'on est créatif
ou à l'analytique et peut du coup les
gauchers ils sont plus de côté compris
en huitième position il facile le
poisson rouge aurait une mémoire de
quelques secondes
alors là je ne suis pas d'accord mon
pote max bird par le coup a fait une
vidéo
l'année où nous commencions à en faire
lui mois sur youtube en 2016 et cette
vidéo a passé le million de vues cette
année donc vraiment beaucoup de
personnes sont au courant que c'est une
bêtise peut arrêter de dire ça et je
vais vous mettre la fiche ci dessus et
dans la description en tout cas il a été
mené deux fois démontré que les poissons
en général avait une mémoire qui pouvait
aller jusqu'à plusieurs mois alors
arrêtez de les laisser dans des petites
aquarium tout vide avec rien à faire
parce que ça c'est de la torture par
septième classe le cerveau reptilien
c'est le cerveau des instincts primaires
qui nous qui nous rend à notre état
sauvage et tout et tout tu vois qu'il
aura grassi fait tout
bon ben ça c'est pas vrai non plus c'est
à cause de paul maclean qu'on en est là
vers 1960 ce neurophysiologiste
américain a expliqué que le cerveau
serait en fait trois cerveaux les uns
sur les autres clubs qui lie à l'olympic
le néocortex mais surtout que ces trois
cerveaux avaient des fonctions
distinctes les uns des autres et c'est
là où il se plante c'est très sexy de se
dire que le cerveau reptilien c'est les
instincts primaires et le nomic les
émotions et le neocortex la réflexion
mais en fait ça c'est juste une image
hyper simplifiée très simplifié trop
simplifié d'ailleurs c'est pratique pour
faire des métaphores
mais c'est tout dès les années 70 donc
dix ans après sa découverte l'été
démontré que ces trois cerveaux sont
complètement interconnectés et bossent
ensemble sans aucune séparation possible
sixième place notre cerveau nous fait
percevoir la réalité c'est fiable c'est
sûr c'est du bon matos ça et surtout
c'est encore faux maintenant je suis pas
ici
la seule chose dont on est sûr c'est que
tu es tout court parce que tu penses
toujours et ça c'est marrant et je te
donne à like pour la qualité de toutes
les régions et donc non car il associe
en permanence plein de fragments de la
formation qu'il interprète pour donner
ensuite ce que l'on croît être la
réalité c'est à la fois un simulateur de
données mais aussi un tricheur dans
l'interprétation des résultats et se
voit parce qu'il est plein de matière
grise qu'il est toujours bon et qu'il a
toujours raison
je vous invite à voir mon deuxième
épisode de matière grise pour en faire
l'expérience par vous même
comme par hasard
oui tout à l'heure non plus 5e place on
pourrait doper notre intelligence
non on peut s'aider à la concentration
mais la seule manière d'améliorer son
intelligence globale sa culture et sa
logique c'est d'expérimenter un maximum
de choses et de créer de nouveaux
circuits neuronaux dans notre cerveau en
gros pour que le cerveau s'améliore il
faut améliorer son plaisir d'apprendre
et augmenter augmenter sa curiosité au
global tu veux dire
ite c'est-à-dire loïc ouais c'est vrai
mais en fait ce titre n'était pas un
hasard la curiosité c'est la meilleure
arme du cerveau on avance dangereusement
la quatrième place allez plutôt rapide
on n'utiliserait que 10% de notre
cerveau on l'utilisé à 100% mais pas
toutes les zones en même temps exact
loïc bodin suffit suivant troisième
place il faut absolument apprendre par
coeur à l'attention
l'apprentissage par coeur n'est pas à
délaisser parce que ça fait fonctionner
certains types de mémoire qui sont
utiles pour le reste de notre cerveau
cognitif
il ya quelques années j'en doute et
j'avoue mea culpa mais ça a été démontré
ces dernières années donc je me mets à
jour par contre on sait également que
l'acquisition et l'encodage de
l'information passe par la comparaison
la compréhension
l'imagination donc on est très loin du
par coeur à tout prix quand même
deuxième place ne rien faire penser à
tous a rien à n'importe quoi à rêvasser
n'est pas utile et n'est pas stimulant
pour le cerveau alors là non plus des
chercheurs canadiens ont réussi en 2009
à faire différentes d'imagerie cérébrale
des personnes qui étaient en train de
rêvasser
résultat le cortex préfrontal très
frontal préfrontal était à fond et
l'analyse est possible par exemple mais
en fait tu avais lu le texte
d'aujourd'hui
bah ouais ça c'est des idées reçues ce
que tu avais à la base
totem ou d'halloween en tout cas il
n'est pas rare que des solutions à des
problèmes se trouvait en faisant rien de
spécial ou en étant aux toilettes où on
n'est pas en train de se promener
il te faut un peu se promener aux
toilettes en même temps ou comme le truc
de newton qui en marchant a reçu comme
sur la tête et il aurait trouvé il
aurait trouvé la gravité sauf que à ce
moment là c'est parce qu'il a trouvé ces
qui se débloque un truc dans sa
réflexion
bon donc je plein d'exemples comme ça et
je ne donnerai pas plus et enfin la
première place
magic complètement magique être bon en
maths est une question de volonté
alors non pas forcément et en écrivant
cette vidéo j'ai découvert un truc
dingue
il existe un cas très méconnu qui a un
peu la dyslexie des calculs et qui
s'appelle la dyscalculie
alors c'est une sorte d' affection qui
touche quand même deux millions
d'adultes en france et j'ai pas encore
trouvé les chiffres pour les enfants
mais c'est quand même c'est énorme ça
veut pas dire que tout le monde est
atteint par la dyscalculie par ce
trouble mais je trouve que c'est quand
même à prendre en considération et que
dès qu'un enfant a des grosses
difficultés en primaire à retenir toutes
ces tables d'addition une multiplication
ou même même par exemple la table de
5,86 de la table de 2 ça peut être de la
dyscalculie c'est pas forcément il est
nul en maths il s'intéresse pas il se
concentre pas donc lui comprendre les
maths les apprendre les manipuler ça
demande une concentration et on peut
vraiment y arriver tous sauf ceux qui
ont une difficulté particulière
le trouble de la dyscalculie voilà il
faut il faut faire connaître ce trouble
là aujourd'hui il est évident tant quand
un adulte par exemple a du mal à lire à
écrire et qu'il nous dit je suis
dyslexique on sait ce que c'est et on ne
juge pas saab il faudrait qu'ils aient
la même chose pour la disculper
merci avec celle castle d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo vous pouvez
tester gratuitement le jeu en passant
par le lien dans la description et les
nouveaux joueurs en plus reçoivent 250
diamant et 3500 pièces d'argent ainsi
s'achève ces idées reçues sur ce gros
organes gros manques et le cerveau je
vous recommande d'enchaîner avec cette
vidéo là où je présentais pas moins de
dix-neuf fait insolite sur le cerveau ou
l'autre vidéo avec loïc et céline où
nous faisions un vrai ou faux sur le
cerveau qui vous débarquez sur cette
chaîne je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard vous pouvez vous abonner c'est
gratuit et j'ai dit aussi comme disait
loïc à un magazine mensuel papier que
vous recevez chez vous dont vous pouvez
lire quelques pages dans la description
ces curieuses merci à très bientôt
ciao